testiamo quanto conoscete il mio canale
quindi fate la intro vi prego niente
l'ho già allora ragazzi questo
preferiresti voi sapete benissimo che
cosa siamo sapete valori spiega un
attimo al voto allora loro ci danno un
opzione all altra e noi dobbiamo
scegliere quello di ok una canzone che
vi fanno i fatti non le piace non le
piace
perfetto allora la prima domanda a casa
a fagiuolo se non è la prima è prefissi
essere gay o avere il diabete
quindi preferirsi avere il diabete e
basta va bene va bene a questa
preferiresti non poter più ascoltare
musica o non più paul poter non guardare
più le serie tv certo questo è difficile
se no le serie tv
no c'è non non più le serie tv guarda
ascolta solo musica
beh vabbè ma la musica o la musica
importante
preferiresti essere sposato con marco
marino può essere accusato da marco
marino andiamo allora preferirsi essere
miley cyrus e selena gomez
questo anche perché sulla tomba
significa maggiori essere mai però parti
si stava bene a questa questo per tutti
ma perché si essere ricco ma stare con
una vecchia con una vecchia oppure
essere povero ma pieno di quindi
potrebbe essere adatto no sì sì è la
risposta può vivere a narnia o vivere ad
hogwarts mille volte che ci vorrei
pensare effettivamente provveduto di
casa ma non vuol dire che se ti piace
riportati per forza dire forward magari
daniele armadio quindi ne va bene ma se
avete mai provato a chi rovina una
tematica quando c'e narnia io ci
conquistiamo poveri armati
ma inoltre seriamente lo strozzino
all'assenza netflix o senza playstation
senza playstation e playstation che
tanto non si debba uscire senza quella
pubblica tavola ultimo lavoro quindi per
forza perché questa perché un pressing
ei che si innamora idioti innamori di
una lei subito ma perché vuol dire
aspettà l'importante le lesbiche e
diabete la lesbica di avete bravo
diciamo perché sennò ok questa è carina
questa è carina la pizza collana naso la
carbonara con la panna
ma sai che mia mamma l'altro giorno ma
viva l'altro agli impianti te lo giuro
non continuare queste storie per perché
anche perché mettere emettere un
avanzati andiamo avanti ragazzi cinque
sono le cose orribili a pizza colonia
non sai no sei fuori della famiglia c'è
la pizza con anas è più buona della
calcolato lapandry una delle due cose
star che feriscono fisco di gentaglia
tribolare
scusatemi ecco preferirsi essere pelato
ma bello oppure cappelluto ma brutto
io sono capelluto ma bello bellissimo
preferirsi vivere nel mondo di hogwarts
di razzi spacca tutto magari fuori da
questa casa a casa vostra questa niente
fogli vado io vedrei la vostra casa mia
ora però vi ispirate al circolo di un
suo video che ho doppiato lo chiamano
questa ti stacchi netti ma la church
disney non c'è concesso di vivere con
molti amici ma finti o con nessun amico
nessun amico differenza mario essere il
figlio di domenico di domenico bini o il
figlio di youtube o anche io farò essere
youtube anche io
sapete che sono entrambi
a quanto pare però essere youtube anche
io mangiarsi un sacco di marmellate
vorrei comunque domenico pini e ogni
presente nelle domande va bene morire e
torturato morire bruciato allora adesso
che sono decisamente di ball in
un'esplosione o tipo con la sabbia a me
e mettere in forno a 30 gradi per sante
fare danni o un medesimo sto video per
fini si passare una giornata con la tua
ex o una giornata della persona che ho
di io non odio le mie ex comunque
bannato supplica persona al mondo ben
sotto la loro copia non è quindi allora
l'ultima domanda ve la faccio io e non
c'entra nulla con preferiresti ma è una
cosa sceglieresti di questo gruppo di
quattro persone
se dovessimo scambiarci i canali e non
guardate numero di iscritti che canale
vorresti di sedersi scambiare tuo comune
e ciò che ho un canale come un solo
video delle dico che voglio morire
non voglio provare un le ha risposto il
tuo adesso che mi ha fatto quello che
vuoi fare i disegnini fantastico io ho
sempre avuto fare il gameplay per anche
iniziato quando ero giovane poi ho detto
ai miei giocatori non fare nulla quindi
giovanni date quindi quello di charlie
[Applauso]
chi vince mario party va bene dire
grazie per questo video incredibilmente
poco per i freni non ne vogliate male
vi voglio molto bene grazie bisogno
canale tanto non ci abbiamo più voglia
xvi per scherzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto lasciato un bel commento ma
sotto sulle prossime domande da farci
possono preferire sì ringrazio c'è
schiacciarli e giovanni trovati loro
account social in the description volete
un telecomando noti sempre noi ci
vediamo a del prossimo video non le tre
carte non ho più voglia di farlo di tipo
il con telecomando ciao
[Musica]